look take a look who's here We snuck in
Maurice Ashley in the studio with us
Maurice welcome welcome to St Louis
welcome back to the show what brings you
here
St Louis is the chess tournament
happening right I figured I would show
up yeah there is absolutely and you've
participated as a commentator in U.S
championships all throughout the years
for so many years uh how do you feel
about this year's championship what's
different
um well there's some slight controversy
that was preceded this tournament and so
certainly a lot of people are interested
in seeing how that developed it's a
whole new world now I mean I left chess
for one year to go do my writing and and
my chess courses and all hyperloose I
mean it's been wild so I think that that
has kept people on their edges of their
seats and now we're seeing delay 30
minute delay going on and all the new
security measures it's some of it quite
sad for me but um it's it's what it
seems like it's needed talk to me about
that a bit did you go to the plane Hall
at all did you get uh checked no I'm not
getting Mom dude
all the craziness no I haven't been to
the playing Hall I literally just landed
and then Tom said get in the chair so
yeah that's why I'm here but uh it I
think it's kind of strange I mean it's
we used to just basically trust people
and now the paranoia is complete and it
just I think a very sad thing for our
game how do you feel all these new
measures change the dynamic of the game
follow players for the commentators
maybe even for spectators I think with
the spectators it's the worst thing I
think the players will just take it in
stride they are just playing chess as
they always have I think for us as
commentators or for you as commentators
you you're probably more assured that
you know it's legit and you get to talk
about a little bit more interesting
stuff stuff that's just crazy though I
mean admittedly when when people are
taking pictures of people being wanded
in certain body parts like that's over
the top I I can't but for the spectators
I think it's the worst part because as a
fan you used to be able to go into the
room see the players soak up some of the
atmosphere see these great Giants that
you're you love so much
and now it's like no you're not allowed
in you can't have that and we we've been
dying for years and years as chess
commentators as ambassadors of the game
we want to bring the fans in and now
it's no you can't walk in so I think
that's for me the saddest part of the
whole thing it's definitely a new Chess
World now uh we're going to work you a
little bit yeah I don't even know what's
happening in the position I told you I
just landed first of all this is what
happened in the game between Fabiano and
a Wonder check this out Knight F6 Knight
E5 Knight takes E4 usually a rookie
blunder what is this exactly that's what
we thought as well and take a look he
actually equalized out of the opening I
wonder that is I Wonder has been playing
some funky stuff yeah you gotta admit
you know he keeps saying I'm just a
student yes I'm not really serious and
then he bashes the Ronin over the head
uh you know all these these crazy
openings we're seeing I think when
you're free you can just play chess and
it's a nice place to be no pressure I
don't have to win uh I don't have to win
the tournament big deal I'm a college
student you could just play and you can
experiment and that's not I don't think
the veterans
like to see the young guys being like
this like I don't care I'm just going to
play anything I want against you I mean
Fabi doesn't win this game it'll be
embarrassing like who plays 94 against
you in a petrol thing and equalizer
speaking of Fabi uh how do you feel
about his performance so far he's been
having a rough year the Olympia the
candidates but now finally it seems like
he's back do you feel the same way the
world's not right without Fabiano
caruana playing good chess like the
chess world's just not right we need to
see him playing well he was a number two
player in the world cemented as such for
so long he was a great Challenger to
Magnus uh fabi's got to be playing well
you see Fabian number what did he drop
the number 12 once or I think he's back
at number five but I mean but he drops I
mean he dropped out of the top ten
Fabiano caruana that's outrageous so to
see him back in the hunt the thing
though about Fabi that's crazy is he
only won one U.S Championship like when
he won his first one we said oh man this
is it he's going to just run them up
he's the best player in the U.S he
hasn't won one since which is insane so
the world should be said it right if he
keeps this up and does what he needs to
do and wins again no surprise to anybody
it's good to see him playing good chess
that was actually the first year he came
uh and represented the United States
that's only one instantaneously yeah
that was his first one and the last one
let's uh wait and see whether he has to
be able to win this one as well hasn't
Wesley won like a couple in between I
think three of them since
exactly that's crazy despite him being
the number one player in the country
Maurice what are you doing nowadays you
were talking about courses writings
what's uh what's he says exactly what
I'm doing I did a course for chessable
the secrets of Chess geometry doing
quite well I also wrote a children's
book
that's going to be coming out next year
I'm in the process now of writing
another book on chess and uh and then
next about to sign a deal to do yet
another book it looks like I'm fully in
content creation mode I'm like yes
everyone
as many books as he has so I'm having a
lot of fun with that I also I'm doing a
lot of corporate speeches corporate
engagements and some traveling as well
coming up in November I'll be going to
Senegal with my two children I've been
to Africa many times but now I finally
get to take the youngins on our first
family trip if you will to Senegal to
Africa so that's something I'm really
excited about and if I'm not mistaken
you also have a trash talking chess app
that's correct
it's okay it's okay you know apps are
tricky things to make any money off but
it has some of my best teaching ideas in
it absolutely yes sir well first of all
good to see you welcome back welcome
back is the U.S Championship would have
been incomplete without your uh Maurice
so uh welcome welcome welcome uh expand
a little bit on the children's book uh
how are you going to inspire kids uh
with your children's book what do you
what are you what are you teaching well
it's not a it's not a chess book per se
like specifically I don't know where my
camera should be right now am I looking
at this camera it's not it's not a chess
book per se it's uh it's a book about my
early life so it's more of an
inspirational motivational book gotcha
and that way I talk a little bit about
growing up in Brooklyn getting the trash
talking as you mentioned from back in
the day when I was playing in the
hustlers in the park and also my first
time playing chess and uh and you know
stuff I'm writing actually includes you
in it yes me yeah honestly one little
scene between me and you uh when I met
you remember Mikhail tile that game that
I I showed that sacrifice with you play
against komsky yes with kamsky yeah
defected in that tournament New York
open right yes exactly exactly so I I am
definitely going way back but to talk
about humble beginnings and focusing on
loving something being passionate about
something and becoming successful at it
nice okay an inspirational book well
Anastasia do you have any questions for
our colleague of course of course I
wanted first of all to ask Maurice how
many calls he got during these times
when this drama has started and maybe
something interesting any story behind
the scene for you with this whole
cheating scandal yes yes well
I one story comes to mind I'm not sure I
can say
so I got I got calls I got a lot
of Wall Street Journal
uh NBC you name it there was everybody
was giving me phone calls they wanted me
to do an interview and and I've got a
matter of fact after I leave here I'm
going to be on New Zealand television
with another call New Zealand it's been
so far but speaking of that part of the
world Australian television reached out
to me and I did this interview
and the
I don't know if I could say but we have
a 30 minute delay all right so we can
come in a 30 minute delay
in the middle of the interview he says
to me tell me tell me about vibrating
you know what beats like this is in the
middle of an interview which they ended
up being on air and I said I don't want
to talk about that topic you know like
sex toys
and uh and then he and I said that's the
way the brain goes now and he says yeah
you're right it looks like nowadays we
just go straight for the
[Laughter]
I guess they do it different in
Australia wow but he had no problem
talking about it and bring it up so
first time I I think somebody has
interviewed me and I was at a loss for
words of what to say afterwards because
you know me I always have something to
say but this time wow
Maurice question for you buddy have you
ever had a game whether it be online or
at the board where you felt something
was wrong with your opponent like you're
getting gained or something was
happening that just didn't sit well with
you online or over the board
uh I would say over the board of Denver
never never I've never felt no no over
the board no no but online when I've
been on stream it did happen that once I
was playing with uh Irina in hand and
brain and we were playing against a
player who was supposed to be about 17
1800 and all the persons all the players
moves were like yesterday
you know we were looking we were you
know it was uh streaming yeah so we
could see and we were like um it's 1800
it's kind of strong
they were dropping bars you know like
nuances I mean I could have been playing
we could have been playing you yesterday
right so so we kind of felt funny in
that one I must admit okay but that's
the only time interesting it's also
interesting for me to know Maurice what
do you think about the women chess
championships because we have many
different players this time youngsters
foreign
love I love it when you see the
youngsters starting to excel like that's
the best thing you can have so the
youngsters showing it yeah we have
Fabian we have Dominguez and you know
and we have Irina and the vet so we love
and we've been with for years right
right grown up in front of our eyes and
maybe even growing older in front of our
eyes but without the future then there's
nothing there's just it's just the way
it should be and so it's good to see
young blood on the on the female side
and women's side for sure seeing them
not be not be afraid at all like just
absolutely Fearless they're here to show
no respect to their to their Elders in
fact I mean this word disrespect has
been a part of this Championship who
knew that this would be the disrespect
U.S Championship but uh I think it's
right I think the youngster should be
like I'm here I've seen you enough I
played you enough now they're some
mainly veterans even the young players
are like veterans in the field they
should be thinking We Got Game Show Me
What You Got and so I'm excited to see a
sort of Shifting at the top I don't
think it's a full change of the Guard
yet you know you can't tell Fabi he's
old but but it should be that the
youngsters start to show their stuff and
and we know that the future is bright in
U.S chess absolutely Maurice is
wonderful to see you thank you how long
are you in town for I'll be here for
Until the End wow brilliant Finish Line
I know oh my God
come to the cold in the midwest when I
could be in Florida
you know on the beach right but I get
the beach all the time anyway now that
I've moved down there so I'm gonna hang
out well we'll pull you in more often uh
where are you hanging out over at the
chase
you know we can't tell where we're
asleep oh that's right stalkers yeah
commentators are in great demand yeah I
remember we need to get you on the
podcast
lovely Maurice again great to see you
welcome welcome welcome thank you thank
you absolutely and of course wonderful
good luck on the chessable courses I
know that Maurice is also